今年の年末年始はちょっといろいろしてて
実家に帰れませんでした
はじめしゃちょーです！
あーーーーーーーー
ママーーーーーーエンアーーーーーー
ちょっとねじいちゃんばあちゃんには会いたいんですけども
なかなか帰れなかったんですけども
そんな僕にちょっと
マミーから届きました
とやまはラーメンを色で呼ぶ。
５食分入ってて
スープがついてる
富山県のカラーラーメンというものらしいです
ここにお母ちゃんのメッセージが書いてるわけよ
５色ラーメンです。めんは同じようなのでいっしょに作れます。年越しそばにどーぞ。
アハハンアー
母ちゃんありがとう
年越えちゃった
これそばじゃない
ラーメンや
年末もさみしいだろうと思って
こういうの送ってくれるとこで
もう感謝感謝ですよ
富山県のラーメンはね
色がねすごい
カラフルみたいな話を聞いたことがあります
５色ですね
白、黄色？
白、緑、赤、茶色、黒
ブームっていうか、
やっぱすごいらしいよ
富山県のラーメンは
なんかね、実家がそういう
ラーメンでね有名だと嬉しいね
うわぁ～
こんな感じになっております
ちょっとねこういうの見ると
富山に帰りたくなるわけよ
すげぇ！
こういう感じで５食
ラーメンが入っております
今日は、ただ、夜ご飯を食う動画です。
富山県に帰れない！
そんな悲しい俺に
マミーが届けてくれた
らっ・・・ラーメン！
さ、大事なのはここからだ。
俺が本当にラーメンが作れるかどうかですね。
とりあえずちょっと適当にやってみようと思います
まずは
待ってなんか作り方が書いてあるはずなんだよね
麺は沸騰したたっぷりのお湯でお好みにΨπΘ§Αδ・・・
分かった！
とりあえずゆでよう！とりあえずゆでよう！
とりあえずゆでます！
とりあえずゆでればいい
うん、ですよね
OKゆでるぐらいなら僕でもできるよ
OK
これでゆで・・え？
ゆでたらどうするんだろう！？
ゆでた後がよくわからんぞ
あれ？富山ブラックは？あった
麺は沸騰したたっぷりのお湯でお好みにより約２分半～３分ゆでてください。
丼に、添付のスープを入れ、熱湯300mlで溶いてラーメンスープを、　ほうほうほう。
難しい！
今から、ラーメンを5つ作る。
5つ作るということは、容器が5ついる
1 、待って5つもあるかな？
あ、あるある！
よかったよかった
1，2，3，4，5　　キターー！
もういいかな？
決まった。今日は作る、今日は作る。
ラーメンぐらい・・、ラーメンってこんなさ、沸騰してるわ！
うわぁー
中身こういう感じでしか入ってないから、結構シンプルだね。
麺を全部、ぶち込みます。
これさ、誰でも作れるんじゃね？
うわーー!
これで2,3分入れるだけでしょ
麺は全部同じなので
まとめて麺をやっちゃってもいいってことね
麺が全部同じだから
一緒に混ぜてもいいってことか
けど、一個目入れちゃった
まて、どうしよう
いや、深く考えるな
簡単なことだ
僕は猫舌だった
ブラックラーメンどこ!
説明書、ねえ!
沸騰してるから
ちょっと、沸騰してる沸騰してる
俺マジどこ行ったっけ、ブラックの説明書
待って早くしないと後2分
1回切りまーす
落ちてたー!
麺がゆであがったらしっかりお湯を切り
添付のスープを入れ
熱湯300mlで溶いてラーメンスープを準備します
熱湯がいる
しっかりお湯を切ってこっちに移す
あー
はい、というわけで無事5色のラーメン出来ました
寂しいね
いただきまーす
うまい
ブラックラーメンは
富山でもかなり有名なので
全然食べたことはあるんですけども
うまいんですよ、ブラックラーメンはホントに
じゃあ次、グリーン行きます
でもホントにグリーンだね麺とか
いただきます
うまいよ全然
次レッド
これも、結構思った以上にレッドなんですよ
かっら…(辛い)
じゃあ次ホワイトいただきます
いただきます
うわぁ、うめぇ
うまいけど汗が…
あの、実はブラウンが一番おいしいと思っている。俺は
よく見る色だもん
いただきます
うん…いいんじゃない…
多いな
一人で食うにはちょっと多かったです
腹減ってたんでなんとかここまで来たんですけども
僕はここで本日の本題に移りたい
この5色のラーメンを混ぜると何色になってどんな味になるのか
とりあえず、麺たいらげよ
赤行きまーす
はいよーー
グリーン行きます
あっ、ホワイトで取り戻してほしいな。ホワイト入ります
ブ、ブラウン入ります
問題は味ですよ味
いただきます
よくわかんない